hello there oh that's what everyone's
saying on youtube i bet right
right greg and john here joined by ace
ace has to get up bright and early
because he has his own panel at star
wars celebration to do yes he is the
biggest star wars guy that i know and i
was like you gotta join us for obi-wan
we're trying to get him on here for a
while keep saying no we're looking
people follow you ace squad leader ace
on twitter and instagram and my youtube
channel at first cup you guys watch
movie trivia movie trivia star wars
champ over here you better bring the
goods today you better bring the goods
pressures on pressure's on i gotta know
everything you gotta know everything is
you gotta make us look good and yeah
this is first time ever being here and
we're throwing him into a lion's den two
episodes of obi wan's this is episode
one reaction today full length watch
along where you sync up with the time
code is for our super sexy rejects over
at our patreon page cover a whole bunch
of shows over there as well please leave
a like that would be very much
appreciated and very important subscribe
and click that notification bell get
notified when our reaction for episode
two is up goal is to get that up one as
soon as possible i know i said the
sentence weird sorry about that lastly
then boys at prepper thanks for helping
us edit down these highlights let's get
to it
[Music]
people my god
[Laughter]
okay
i just wasn't sure what planet this was
oh it is oh my god
it's oh my we're gonna see
we're going to see the killing of the
younglings yes oh my god
are we really going to say this right
now
oh my god
jesus order 66 bro
this is incredible
we got live action clone troopers right
here this is so cool
[Music]
i mean
what were you gonna do
[Music]
oh my god what an opening
yeah one of those kids has to be grown
up
i don't care people say i'm never gonna
get sick of tattooing but never hope we
never leave more tattoo we not saying
more sand more sand please more more
there he is
and there's there they are yeah
it's crazy we got inquisitors in live
action it's pretty nuts man i love this
you know what we do
you and jedi in actuality i would say
the jedi hunt themselves
maybe he's looking for people like him
he comes across this establishment
nice place then
he sees
you he's like hans landa from a glorious
bastard you offer him a place to hide
fresh water shade from the sun's in his
undoing
wow
yup that's the safety brother bro oh
damn that's the shafty brother yeah
it's benny right yeah
prepare him for interrogation you're
wasting your time you know that right
you'll never find a song
that'll stop them
it did really slow them down
you are reckless he is not yours to find
we are past this third sister i will not
warn you again mm-hmm third forget this
fixation with kenobi or i will relieve
you of your duties is that clear yes
consider them forgotten i love how she
got so sick of the grand inquisitor's
monologue she has to hear this every day
that's a good point she just threw the
knife
waited for someone
hello there
good to see you again
i'm just so happy you and mcgregor gets
to step back into this world with like
better effects and [ __ ]
i i hope like qui-gon is like his
roommate
he already hangs out with him
do you have it
i'll give you t16
i'll give you 50. but when he's playing
with it
you guys know what i'm talking about
right hey don't ever ask us that
question always assume yes
master
master
he was like i should probably kill that
boy before he turns evil
experience has taught me one thing
for a fleeting moment
i could end it
[Laughter]
that moment passed
[Music]
yeah that's totally it yeah
wow that's we're all thinking about it
same time's crazy
you'll draw too much attention but i
have nowhere to go they're hunting me
you have to help me stay hidden
live a normal life what about the people
that need us what about the fight the
fight is done
we lost
there is a bit of like a little glass
jedi quality to him yeah
except we know he's gonna but i also
feel like that's like oh my god is this
older this is alderwrong
it totally is ah
are we gonna see this
place
oh my god everybody i recognize the
older one right away oh good for you i'm
good for you i'm saying that i mean if
we're going to see a baby luke then baby
leia oh my god that means we're going to
see jimmy smith's baby yeah battles back
baby
and
if you behave i will let you
oh
ah
trying to get some training in wow it's
that one droid we got a little leia here
it's incredible the aging
it's a very lovely prison don't worry
one day that prison will blow up we
talked about this when the time comes he
must be trained like you trained his
father bird anakin is dead
ben and i won't let you make the same
mistake twice so leave him on the farm
with his family where he belongs does he
not know that anakin became darth vader
there's a jedi hiding on this planet we
need to know where he is
don't look at it or you'll be punished
hands go first
that way
when you reach for anything you think of
us you have no rights here
we're not under the empire oh my god
you know something
wife
kids
you think you could protect them from me
tell me where the jedi is or this man
and his family die
oh my god
you know
if you remember anything
rewards will be given stand down third
sister
i love how the inquisitors are like
she's out of control guys
she's
not gonna talk to hr
she's one of the bad ones
she's not a good inquisitor you know
you still want kenobi what is it you
think you will gain by capturing him
when i'm old i wonder if she's like the
one from the
jennifer order
vendetta with a mentor or something
[Music]
can they see you waving
it
thank
thought you was him in the background
you know my father says they never let
you leave this planet they don't want
anybody to know about you because you're
not one of us your father you want him
to like you so you repeat what he says
even though you don't really know what
it means
being like him will make people
frightened of you but really you're the
one who's scared i may not have seen
much
cousin but i can see that
damn laying the law down
why are you here
just waiting
for what
for you
what the hell that's hot
from the chili peppers yes
yes
i was like the side looks like him he's
gonna sit in with max rebo
[Applause]
just ran into that branch
[Music]
good
she's as important as he is it's been 10
years i'm not who i used to be
[ __ ] you
she's like but it's a boy
she's a girl she doesn't matter as much
see how things work
[Music]
oh it's safety
[Music]
could save them obi-wan
scratch the itch dude
huh
i i think so
that's him
papa qui gone
one with the force
he's headed for daru
oh
you're not quite
nah not the first signature behind the
freight transport the ship is on its way
there now there is no one i trust more
with my child than you
for her
one last fight
god i love you with mcgregor's
performance in this
is so
so much pain
in his eyes dude so many great little
nuances my father will rescue me he'll
send a whole army
no one's coming for you
there's some cheesy acting from time to
time
i think it's maybe him
i kind of like flea
i'm more distracted by it the fact that
it's i think that's the biggest
distraction
he's gonna pull it out
the lightsaber whip it out man
he's immediately just going to cut it
open in lane
first so much better first resort
[Music]
i love it
he fought beside a father during the war
he'll come the jedi will hunt himself
damn she knows who leia really is
well
you're coming or not
[Music]
is
[Music]
this is like his logan
what that was an hour yeah that felt
like it was a half hour
that went by so fast it's about 48
minutes
oh that went by so quick didn't it oh my
god i really thought there was like 30
more minutes left didn't it this is all
about leia
yeah it's kind of amazing biggest
surprise i love that we got to move on
to the next episode so we'll just talk
for just a couple of minutes because
yeah it's really late at night that
we're probably this yeah
but uh so keep a lookout for them but
but yeah let's just wait to see if
there's a post credits and we'll talk
about it a little bit i don't think
there's a post credit scene no
especially probably
not if they put two episodes at once
yeah this is just the first time ever
the screening and the streaming service
has been like you know what
just watch the credits
yeah that's true they don't need to
shuffle you into something else next
episode next episode you're done with
this new show hey we got so much stuff
all right i mean i thought it was a
really good first episode we got another
episode of watch so we there's no need
for us to talk for super long but right
now what i'm currently loving is eva
mcgregor's performance uh primarily joel
edgerton's and uh like as usual the
effects are really good i like the setup
of the story a lot there are times where
it what i find interesting is weird i
don't know if you guys will agree with
me at all of this
what i found a little funny
is
joel edgerton and um
and even mcgregor are back and they're
giving such like a gritty realistic
performance it's so like real and such
an antithesis to help the prequel acting
often felt
and then there are other performances
that kind of feel like they're in the
prequest
like a little bit like the safety
brother felt a little cheesy to me the
riva character someone i don't really
find sometimes it feels like acting to
me whereas the other ones feel so like
those two feel so real and some of these
other people like the little little leia
feels like child actor good one charming
but yeah that's just kind of my opinion
but i still really enjoyed it a lot i'm
really loving the themes of you know
facing your your traumas and um and also
like yeah this whole thing of he never
really seemed to give a [ __ ] about me
and now he's going out there to go look
after her and protect her and especially
that'll tie in even stronger to the
whole thing of help me obi-wan kenobi
your only hope there's a tiny one
stronger than that um
so yeah uh i i think jimmy smits can be
in back his tubes and seen ultron you
know
things like that's really exciting i
know he's gonna have a lot to say so
john why don't you go first there's an
alderaan referencing californication
flea cameo at
all in damn so put down my every
youtubers your job is to you know i'm
just being like kind of critical just to
you know you balance the scales here so
don't like kiss asses so yeah john you
go next i mean that's the funny thing is
to me like
i think everybody's gonna have a sort of
different experience with which
characters blend in the most and which
ones kind of stick out and to me it was
the safety brother actually who i was
like i've seen this guy give amazing
performances and i was like
this is all adr and all just like little
exposition lines so yeah it's it's it's
interesting to me i like the pace
they've chosen for this i like that it
is a uh more something more i started
listening to it to that legends book
about uh part of it is about you know
like obi-wan living on tatooine and some
of it is sort of similar to what's going
on here and i like that they've gone
with something that is more
contemplative even though you have the
looming threat of the inquisitors even
though you have riva who i really
enjoyed uh here and uh yeah it's
building to something that's a nice
subversion to me from the at least
promos that we saw thinking okay it's
all gonna be about him keeping an eye on
luke and mentoring luke uh and so yeah
to divert from that i think is really
cool and i yeah i just love what ewan
mcgregor is doing at the core of this to
anchor it it's like there's a lot that
we're focusing on and establishing and i
think he has a nucleus to all that and
just as a performance you know to ground
everything is is really beautiful and
and all the sort of body language that
he's put in is terrific true true
ace my man dude what did you think uh i
talked to the audience
to be honest i loved it but obviously
that's a
it's kind of obvious coming from me uh
considering that you know i love ob1 but
the prequels i mean the amount of
prequel i kept saying it throughout the
reaction but the amount of prequel love
that we got
throughout this was like just insane
i've never seen that much like prequel
callback and obviously the show is this
is the first time the show is you know
touching on the prequels usually we've
seen the mandalorian and boba fett which
are you know focused
right after return of the jedi
but still
prequel love i'm here for and and i love
it and i love that it's so far that
everything we've seen
is
as long as you've seen the prequels
you're good you know i mean obviously
the visitors are you know
after that but i feel like
that's a really cool idea as far as like
saying like remember this stuff this is
the main core
of what the story is about uh second
thing for me is the land stuff is just i
mean obviously you mentioned it john but
to me it's like
it's always been that question that a
lot of people have always had
which i find funny that the show just
tackled it head-on which is why luke why
not leia and why is all this focus on on
why does it have to be a little boy why
can't it be the little girl
and obviously yoda says in return of the
jedi i mean emperor's expect but it's
one of those dude
but it's one of those questions i know
you messed up god
out of here
uh but it's one of those questions that
people have always had which is like
why all this focus on luke and why not
on leia who's keeping an eye on leia i
think it says george lucas came up with
it a little bit later
[Laughter]
but it's always been that kind of funny
remark as far as like obi-wan looking
after luke and even in this episode
where he's like but it but it's luke
though it's it's the glory it's the boy
i'm after the boy he even said the boy
like twice yeah and it's like always
been that kind of funny thing as far as
like it has to be a board yeah which is
kind of a cool bait and switch that the
show has really done like the show
really did
try to convince us as far as
trailer-wise that it's gonna be
obi-wan on the run and maybe some you
know looking after luke kind of stuff
but not anything having to do with leia
yeah so that that to me is the coolest
and obviously seeing alderaan again
after revenge of the sith it's i mean i
recognized it and i was just like oh my
god we're going to see leia we're going
to see all iran yeah well i think living
in the lifestyle of alderaan is really
cool yeah actually we've never seen what
it looks like inside
yeah like anywhere yeah yeah i mean not
just even aesthetically but you know
really getting a sense of what the
people are like in the environment and
such
um i really like that i i would say i
really really like the like i'm not on
quite the the lo there are things i
definitely loved about the pi about this
first episode and i would say overall i
really really liked i think like what
was smart is like how you were talking
about with the prequels
of knowledge is that they're grounding
this in the emotionality of it all first
and foremost and that's the big part of
like even mcgregor's performance is
something out of logan you know and i
find i do find the whole relationship
the the con the conflicting relationship
with him and uncle owen to be the most
compelling part and it does make sense
to kind of go in a different direction
otherwise you just have another show on
tattoo you know luke
you know obi-wan being like well i won't
just give him my gifts man
take my gifts and give it to luke i'm
looking after him
we gotta we gotta throw in some new
enough things because it's another show
where like you know a reluctant hero is
about to go look after a kid i mean
there's like other there's comics and
books and such where they could have
pulled stories from but it's like a big
part of star wars is not just directly
adapting stuff like letting that be its
own canon letting that exist but then
doing a different story with the shows
and the movies so i think doing this
story fills in something pretty
interesting that i didn't see coming i
do think some of the there is parts of
the filmmaking that at times feels like
this is the most realistic star wars
thing i've ever seen and then
and then other times i'm like sometimes
this feels so much like a tv show though
and so that's where i kind of go back
and forth with some of the aesthetic
like i feel like with the riva character
that's what third sister is called yeah
but yeah uh with that character i feel
like i'll be back and forth because i
love the setup of her i love the
i actually love the writing of her i
like how she like she undercuts all the
inquisitors like i'm not one of you i'm
actually better and i have a bigger
objective than all of you
and so like even undercutting the grand
inquisitor which a lot of people were
excited about
and and so uh i like i really like the
setup of her but yeah there are times
where i'm not sure what it is i don't
mind it's not like a weird thing to be
like there's something about it that
doesn't quite read as i don't really
believe it
but i'm not i don't i don't know how to
explain it at times it feels
like it it hops back forth feeling like
something's so cinematic and then
something feeling like this is a
tv show i think it might come in some of
that clash of direction and it's
interesting because yeah like there are
takes on star wars that get more
naturalistic in terms of performance and
tone and there are the older movies that
have a different aesthetic when it comes
to those things and i feel like they're
both at work here and it's kind of
blending so that's why i kind of like it
because it's sort of blending both like
the prequels and the original trilogy in
terms of tone so part of me kind of
likes that i sometimes feel that way
it's interesting because to me it's it's
not necessarily like oh my god this is
the most amazing episode i've seen but
it it it felt like a steady solid place
to first start first yeah like i i
thought it was a very nice set off into
the journey and and you know i also too
appreciate that yeah like you said it's
not just about regurgitating specific
plot points and things from extended
material but yeah it's like taking some
of those themes especially of when the
jedi decide not to help which is
something i know that is kind of a theme
explored in some comics and books where
it is obi-wan sort of struggling not to
answer that itch yeah and i like the way
that theme plays in here you know i hope
they continue with it because it seems
like the big debate
going on within him yeah i mean i think
part of that too is like he knows that
if he does help another jedi it could
possibly expose luke
so i think that's a huge part of why he
doesn't get involved because he's like
luke is my priority i can't be helping
anyone else yeah because if i do that
could be exposing luke or leading to
luke so yeah and it makes him really
interesting as the character especially
even though we've seen his anguish in
the past of the prequels we also have
you know the alec guinness version to
look forward to who is very sage and
very comforting and i like this middle
point of that character well
simultaneously though in some parts of
the performance rita's that's an excuse
to not help
you know
it's like
that's true that is absolutely true what
you're saying about it and like the
choice
is true but the same time he's so
aggressively
reluctant and resistant he's beaten
towards any form of helping anything
with jedi and it's like his whole belief
system has been demolished his lifestyle
he was born into
stripped
and just
and empty that it's just like no i
i gotta stay in this cave and watch him
i gotta know they're gonna watch him
yeah it's like is this for the bigger
purpose or is it because you don't
actually want to get involved in your
struggling with your faith essentially
and now it goes back to the whole thing
that you're talking about with like
leia's kidnapped
yeah but
i gotta stay here and watch the boy you
know
like sometimes it is a cop out even
though i am endangering him just by
being good just by being this close and
you know i'm force sensitive so they
might sense me and this girl's
specifically looking for me
um
so yeah it is interesting but uh i'm
loving it so far i feel like it's just
gonna get darker all right guys let's
get to it uh we've got one more to go um
along this with the patron of the day
shout out
scuba steve
scuba
let's face it
if there's anyone on our patreon who
could be a wandering jedi
it's definitely you
except i imagine that you be the kind of
jedi
who would uh use the force for just his
own selfish needs
scuba would go around and just steal
stuff off of poor people i mean like hmm
that pair looks
[Music]
snatch it away like a total [ __ ] but
the best kind of [ __ ] because scuba
is the kind of [ __ ] that when
someone's still in need of help
scuba would still rise to the occasion
and then steal from that bad guy make
sure that bad guy kills whatever good
samaritan is out there and yeah they
laid dead in the street but then he
would steal from that bad whatever that
bad guy took from that good guy scuba
would take from that bad guy meaning he
creates balance in the world hence
why scuba is the perfect person to be a
jedi at our patreon page
i could say hey we're close to a million
subscribers and scuba has been here with
us
with like hundreds of thousands of
subscribers ago sure i could go that
route or i could make some weird
sarcastic not that funny patron of the
day shout out calling scuba an [ __ ]
that's the direction i think scuba
really wants and hopes for you know he's
got that east coast grit on him gee
nah you know i'm just messing around
scuba diving thanks for watching
scoob sith over here thanks for being
around here for so long that would have
probably been a much easier direction of
taking it from the get-go better this is
better thank you for being here for for
a while buddy you're your demand thank
you scuba
[Music]